room for us what do we know about this
sadia um well kimberly i'm still trying
to figure out exactly what this
statement means i'll read it out to you
first and then we can talk about it he
says in it during my nearly 20-year
ownership of chelsea fc i have always
viewed my role as a custodian of the
club his job it is
ensuring that we are as successful as we
can be today as well as build for the
future while also playing a positive
role in our communities i have always
taken decisions with the club's best
interest at heart
i remain committed to these values and
that is why i am today giving trustees
of chelsea's charitable foundation the
stewardship and care of chelsea fc i
believe that currently they are in the
best position to look after the interest
of the club players staff
and fans now i've been trying to figure
out what that means i've been speaking
to lots of other people and generally
the the idea is it's quite vaguely
worded we don't know exactly what it
means but
the chelsea's charitable foundation
which is a trust essentially what he's
done is
created some distance between himself
and the club
and given the decision-making powers to
the foundation now so
it's sort of like if you had any other
typical trust
and you had trustees they would then
make the decisions
now the
the interesting part is that with any
sort of process like this the overall
owner can still end up taking back power
of the club so
trust law is of course very complicated
and i haven't got my head around it just
yet but uh
the decision-making can still come back
to him
if the trust were to be
to be closed
as such um now
i've spoken to
the father of a
first team player at chelsea who says
that
they didn't get a heads up on this it
came as a surprise to them just as it
did to many of us uh seeing that tweet
from the club earlier today which had
the club's statement in it
roman abramovich of course under a lot
of pressure
with everything that's going on in
ukraine
so i guess there was an expectation that
something might happen especially
because
the club's manager thomas tucker in the
lead up to tomorrow's carabao cup final
he was asked about the situation and he
said that it is causing strain on the
players um
he said that it has clouded
the atmosphere uh leading up to such a
big final brandwich of course the owner
since 2003 used to be in the box a lot
watching the games but hasn't been since
2018 when he withdrew that visa
application
in 2018